schönen guten abend das ist ja der
korona gipfel bei bild live mit der
wichtigsten frage geht deutschland
wieder doch wieder in den lockdown die
richtigen fragen heute an helge brauchen
die kanzleramtschef von angela merkel
der korona gipfel drahtzieher sozusagen
im kanzleramt und der mann der jetzt
selber cdu-parteichef werden möchte
wolfgang kubicki deutschlands größte
vielleicht letzte hoffnung im kampf
gegen einen neuen lockdown und
zugeschaltet karl lauterbach der spd
corona papst zugeschaltet aus der
karnevalshochburg aus köln und
zugeschaltet aus münchen markus blume
söders general im team vorsicht in allen
schönen guten abend und die erste frage
direkt in diese runde vielleicht antwort
per handzeichen wer garantiert uns denn
noch allen deutschen dass kein neuer
lockdown kommt
jetzt jemanden unter ihnen vier
nein niemand auch nicht herr kubicki ich
bin der überzeugung dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines
flächendeckenden lockdown sind ganz
deutschland gegen null geht aber
garantien abgeben das haben mich die
letzten zwei jahre gelernt gelehrt kann
keiner ich wundere mich ein bisschen
weil ihr parteichef christian lindner ja
das gesagt hat vor kurzem er hat gesagt
das wird eben nicht das mittel der ampel
sein er hat genau das mit diesem
lockdown versprechen ausgeschlossen
einen neuen lockdown herr kubicki das
heißt schon umgefallen wenn ich sage die
wahrscheinlichkeit gegen null geht gegen
null dann ist das ja identisch lockt
dann hat auch markus söder
ausgeschlossen ende august in london
volker bouffier ausgeschlossen noch vor
einigen wochen lockt dann hat ja
eigentlich auch die kanzlerin
ausgeschlossenheit flächen decken wenn
wir ehrlich sind den wird auch so nicht
geben aber was wir nicht ausschließen
können ist das lokal wenn sie steht da
haben mit instanzen über 1000 lokal die
behörden vor ort auch erklären können
das leben geschlossen werden müssen
schulen geschlossen die frage ist nur
wie viel lokale lockt bei uns diese
garantie von herrn lindner dann
einschließt weil wenn wir flächendeckend
am ende lokale oder regionale locker uns
haben haben wir ja auch ein bundesland
nein wir werden das
infektionsschutzgesetz gerade
novellieren und da wird genau festgelegt
nach welchen kriterien was geschehen
kann und wie gesagt der gesetzentwurf
eingebracht vom letzten donnerstag
morgen wird der in der handlung beraten
das ist ein normales verfahren dass wir
brauchen schon gar nicht mehr kennt und
nach der anhörung wird dann entschieden
wie die endgültige fassung aussieht
nächsten donnerstag verabschiedet werden
lauterbach sind sie am ende derjenige
der lindners garantie linders
versprechen kassiert und der auch ein
cookie dazu bringt dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit eben doch nicht gegen
null geht sondern gegen 100
kubik hat ja recht das ist also lokale
lockt uns durchaus geben könnte und man
muss auch mitdenken also
selbstverständlich kann eine ganz andere
variante und auch kommen also wenn wir
andere variante zum beispiel plötzlich
hätten die deutlich ansteckender ist als
die delta variante oder schlimmer noch
eine variante die der es gelingt die
impfungen zu überwinden das haben wir ja
bei der delta war ja dass wir die stadt
gehabten in form an den teilen auch
schon aber da wäre es denkbar dass ein
anderer da konnte ich sehr viel stärker
über die impfungen weg geht die wir
derzeit verabreichen und verarbeitet
haben dann wären natürlich andere
maßnahmen notwendig von daher hat herr
kubicki recht das ist medizin ich
zumindest ich kann den us mediziner hast
also epidemiologen aussprechen würde es
medizin nicht natürlich keinen sinn
machen ein solches kategorisches
sprechen abzugeben herr blume das klingt
jetzt schon wieder zum einstieg in der
sendung so als gäbe es lockt uns also
regionale lockdown ohnehin und
möglicherweise dann überall in
deutschland regionale lockdown
ich bin etwas verwundert gerade die
letzten beiträge weil sie völlig zu
recht darauf hingewiesen haben dass von
den parteispitzen da zum teil ganz
andere töne in den letzten tagen
gesendet wurden fakt ist ich bin in
tiefer sorge weil natürlich die krone
entwicklung in vielen teilen
deutschlands insbesondere im süden und
osten dramatisch ist und ich bin zum
zweiten in sorge weil die politik mit
den neuen mehrheiten im deutschen
bundestag offensichtlich nicht gewillt
ist den bisherigen kurs bei corona
fortzusetzen also da wird das team
vorsichtig jetzt abgelöst quasi von dem
thema team fahrlässig ich halte es für
schweren fehler dass
wenn man sich voreilig festgelegt hat
dass man die epidemische notlage nicht
verlängern will und damit einen ganz
wichtigen instrumentenkasten aus der
hand gibt und jetzt hektisch versucht
noch irgendwie nach zu stricken das ist
nicht das was gerade die länder jetzt
brauchen deswegen ist gut und wichtig
dass noch in dieser woche der bund
länder gipfel stattfindet wenn wir
ehrlich sind eigentlich schon wieder zu
spät das diskutieren wir gleich noch mal
tiefer vor allen dingen die epidemische
notlage herr braun aber um das noch
einmal festzustellen wenn die ampel sich
da offenbar bewegt gerade und ein
bisschen richtung bayerische linie
wieder tendiert das trödeln wir
gleichauf herr kubicki dann ist die
union ist in bayern die csu und sie sind
mit der cdu die letzte verlässliche
locker und partei für deutschland nein
das geht jetzt überhaupt nicht um die
kategorie locker und ja oder nein
sondern es geht darum die zahlen steigen
massiv und deshalb brauchen wir ein
infektionsschutzgesetz dass die länder
handlungsfähig hält und wenn die ampel
koalition jetzt ein gesetz verabschiedet
wo lauter möglichkeiten zum beispiel
kontakt beschränkungen gar nicht mehr
vorgesehen sind dann kann man eben wie
alle gesagt haben können nicht sicher in
die zukunft gucken dann haben wir aber
ein gesetz was keine vorsorge trifft für
solche schwierigen situation reicht
dieses gesetz das jetzt durch den
bundestag geht am donnerstag im
bundestag beschlossen werden soll am
freitag im bundesrat nicht weit genug
mit derzeitigen zustand sind zum
beispiel kontakt beschränkungen nicht
vorgesehen dass es zu wenig herr blume
ihnen geht das auch nicht weit genug
ich sehe das genauso das ist der
entscheidende punkt wichtige elemente in
diesem gesetz fehlen wir bräuchten eine
klare regelung für das thema zweig plus
ja kubicki ist ja auch eine ganz andere
spur der den letzten tagen für aufsehen
gesorgt mit dem thema 1 g ich glaube das
ist einige grund falsche weichenstellung
wir brauchen mehr an schutz und 2g plus
ist ein wichtiger ein wichtiges konzept
und ja in der tat es fehlen auch
weitergehende regelungsmöglichkeiten für
das thema kontakt beschränkung kontakt
beschränkung kontakt beschränkungen für
ungeimpfte das kann und wird
möglicherweise ein weiterer baustein
sein den wir zumindest brauchen im
instrumentenkoffer und dass die neue
ampel regierung da nicht will es ist
alle möglichen instrumente in die hand
zu nehmen halte ich für einen schweren
fehler herr kubicki lassen sie dann noch
mal mit sich reden an der stelle also
dieses gesetz auszuweiten sind zunächst
einmal scheint ist das ja blume gar
nicht verstanden hat worum es geht weil
ein ski bedeuteten die man kommt in der
alten dem pflegeheim hinein ob chinesen
gtld im dienst getestet
chinesen gegeben ist oder ungeimpfte
nicht getestet worden ist keiner betritt
mehr an einem pflegeheim oder ein
krankenhaus der nicht getestet worden
ist soll wissen mittlerweile dass von
gen von giften auch an infektionsgefahr
rausgehen kann wir haben auch einige
ausbrüche in alten- und pflegeheim die
eingetragen worden sind von kämpfen also
dass sie eine ganz sichere haben sie von
einer traglast weiter nicht verstanden
ja das zweite setzt sie damit besänftigt
oder fehlt ihnen noch das ganze jahr
reiten ist verhängt kubicki
ersatzweise der herr kubicki redet von
der herr kubicki rede von halben schutz
ich rede von doppelten schutz geimpft
und getestet beides zusammen ist nach
menschlichem ermessen das sicherste was
wir im moment haben also gar nicht weil
sei wichtig weil wir wissen das ist
natürlich auch viel falsch negative gibt
ich bin immer begeistert dass sich
ashley bekommen von menschen die zuhause
dokumentieren dass sie die lage nicht im
griff haben herr blum als zusetzt
zunächst selbst darauf hingewiesen er
braucht konkretisierung bei 2g bei 2g
plus die momentan im gesetz gar nicht
vorhanden sind hier konkret kritisieren
dass jetzt wir haben festgestellt dass
die im stationen geschlossen worden sind
ein großer fehler wir brauchen sehr
schnell wieder sehr viele im stationen
weil wir ansonsten wie 20 mio menschen
die gepustet werden müssen wir zwar noch
nicht wo ist das machen wir jetzt die
kontakt beschränkung das sind dabei ist
der punkt dass der punkt von herrn braun
das ist momentan ist momentan unser
problem nicht die kontakt beschränkungen
sondern die wiederherstellung der
handlungsfähigkeit nicht nur der
britische hersteller lassen sie nicht
mit sich reden das kommt nicht rein das
wird nicht obendrauf gepackt auf das
möglicherweise nicht ausreichende
gesetzt was sie da gerade die bundes
darin wie er wenn wir kontakt
beschränkungen brauchen dann musste das
durch parlamentarische beratung
geschehen was wir nicht mehr wollen da
sind wir uns alle einig das ist dass das
ministerpräsidenten der stadt an
verschlossenen türen spricht auch gar
nichts die frage trotzdem ganz klar die
sie bisher nicht beantworten wollten
kontakt beschränkungen lassen sie dann
noch mal mit sich reden kommt dass
nachträglich noch rein in das gesetz wir
haben ja schon kontakt beschränkungen
wenn sie in eine öffentliche
veranstaltung nicht mehr gehen können
außer zweig haben sich eine kontakt
beschränkung für ungemein wenn nicht die
definition des gesetzes wir haben jetzt
mit der epidemischen lage die
möglichkeit zu sagen nur gruppen in
gewisser größe können sich noch brauchen
noch einmal in ramallah weiter würde ich
würde würde ich von der union jetzt
erwarten dass wir auf der grundlage des
entwurfs ist inflationsschutz ist dass
ihre eigene vorschläge einbringen und
nicht einfach nur für die fernsehkameras
organisiert warum bringt die cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion nicht an
ergänzungsvorschläge über den wir dann
beraten können wir haben ehrlich gesagt
momentan die situation dass wir einfach
die epidemische lage verlängern können
und wir könnten noch eine sache machen
da bin ich mit ihnen verstreichen die
ausgangs beschränkungen war die
ausgangssperren haus weil damit nicht
ganz sicher das ist wirklich nicht mehr
machen und ansonsten verlängern weil die
epidemische lage eins zu eins dann ist
die sache schon das geht gar nicht ohne
weiteres weil wir die 3g regel für die
für die betriebe einführen müssen dass
wir müssen das gesetz schon ein bisschen
ändern und und ansprechen wir haben
momentan keine klare regelungen für 2
g.de 2g plus oder für 3g das machen der
momentan auf rechts unsicher und lage
wir haben damit ein gesprochen also
entweder sie wollen eine sichere
grundlage für maßnahmen oder sie wollen
sie nicht